NARRATOR: Santa Claus, you
recognized all over the world.
But did you know
Santa wasn't always
the fat man in the red suit?
This is "Biography."
Before the 1860s,
Santa was represented
as everything from a jolly
elf to a tall gaunt man.
In central Europe,
Santa was even
depicted alongside the
Krampus, a devilish figure
who punishes bad children.
Eh, yikes.
For a long time, Santa didn't
exactly scream yuletide joy.
So where did the man
in red come from?
There is a popular myth
that advertisers invented
the Santa we know and love.
But that's not true.
Actually, an illustrator
named Thomas Nast
helped bring us jolly old Saint
Nick back during the Civil War.
Nast was well-known for
his political cartoons.
He created the elephant
figure that stands
for the US Republican Party.
[elephant trumpet call]
And he may have been the
first cartoonist to give
Uncle Sam his iconic goatee.
Nast drew his first Santa
for "Harper's Weekly"
in 1862 as part of
a political cartoon
supporting Union troops.
Take a closer look.
Santa's style is already
starting to take shape.
He's sporting the
classic white beard.
But check out his outfit.
He's in a stars
and stripes suit.
Nast's first Santa wasn't
exactly the one we know today,
but it was close.
He spent the next two decades
nailing down Santa's look,
eventually landing on the
red-suited rosy-cheeked guy
we know and love.
His interpretation became
the American Santa.
From there, it spread
across the globe.
Santa's new look showed up in
advertisements and magazines.
And American troops
spread the image abroad.
Soon, elements of Nast's design
could be seen in Christmas
traditions all over the world.
So next time you
think about Santa,
remember it could be this spooky
elf on your Christmas cards.
But thanks to Thomas Nast, we've
got the lovable guy in red.
[bell rings]